i'm rob knapp and i work with wolfram
research
in the numerical computation group and
i'm going to be talking about
um progress and optimization in the
wolfram language
so so so mathematical optimization
is basically trying to get the best
possible value of some
function um typically over a set of
constraints but there's lots of
categorizations for optimization it's a
really
common problem that people want to solve
one
categorization is linear versus
non-linear another is constrained versus
unconstrained
and final one that's very common is
local versus global optimization so
global optimum is something
for for all possible the best possible
value of function within
any given set of constraints that you
find
okay an additional category that's
become much more widely used recently
and
we've been working on actively numerical
computation group
is convex optimization and the big thing
about convex optimization is it's
non-linear
or sometimes linear it's constrained and
the optimum you find with convex
functions is always global
so convex minimization problem our
optimization problem is you minimize
some convex function
f or to maximize you minimize minus f of
x
and you have constraints divided by
convex functions g sub i
and possibly linear equality constraints
and so that's something we've worked on
pretty hard for the last few versions
and in fact
my slide navigation is not working
properly so i'll have to do this
so in version 12 we added a whole bunch
of special cases
of convex optimization from linear
optimization
through conic optimization and those are
all
particular cases of con convex
optimization the advantage of these
commands
is that you're able to get things which
is the the dual problem out which
actually gives you lots of information
about the
the problem as being solved and
sensitivity to constraints
and various things like that in addition
we took n minimize and find minimum and
we use in those functions we use the
convex optimization functions
automatically when the problem is
detected as convex so part of the
part of the code base we have is
something that goes through
functions and tries to detect when the
functions are actually convex an
immutable solution or not and if it's
not then n minimize goes back to
its old old methods which are typically
slower and less reliable
all right so in version 12.1 we added
integer variable support for all of
those commands above
and we also added geometric optimization
and this is not a convex problem
but it's actually what's technically
called a log convex problem so it's a
special case of
log convex optimization okay so now for
this
version coming up which we'll call 12.2
for
for
good measure is things we've just
recently added in last year and then one
is complex variable support
another is a general command convex
optimization that sort of subsumes
all of those those functions before
for convenience something called
parametric convex optimization that
allows you to use parameters
in your optimization and solve quickly
for parameters i'll show some examples
of that
robust convex optimization the idea here
is you minimize a function
but you want a minimum that's going to
be valid for all possible values of some
parameters so it's sort of a
different it and parametric convex
optimizations are both themes on a
on a parametric thing and paratosh is
going to be talking about that in the
next half hour meeting
and we also have a method framework for
optimization solvers
that include commercial solvers such as
mosaic girobi
express and nina's going to be talking
about that just after paratosh that's
going to be in about an hour
all right so what's coming in future
versions we'll all get to that later
okay so let's do a couple examples and i
think that
that these examples highlight some of
the things we're able to do within this
this convex framework that make it quite
convenient
okay so i'm going to talk about so let's
minimize a real objective so that the
objective for optimization has to be
real
otherwise you can't talk about a minimum
or maximum because there is no such
thing as a minimum or maximum
in the complex plane and then we've got
constraints
that have expressed this complex
constraint so let's look at this
constraint
z is greater than i what does that mean
well notice that that's a curvy
grader and that's using this vector
greater equal
the inequalities we introduced in
version 12.
and what this means for that to be true
it means that
both the real and imaginary components
both have to be greater at the same time
if they're not both satisfies it's
considered false so basically that means
that the real part of z
has to be greater than or equal to 0 and
the imaginary part of z
has to be greater than or equal to 1. so
now we can enter
constraints like this and you know our
standard form gives them in the notation
pretty much like i had above
now let's let's see how it actually
works in the real point so suppose
z is x plus iy sort of a standard way of
representing a complex number
okay and let's do a complex expand on
that and you'll see that i get
you know x so basically the amount the
real parts
have to be matched so basically this
means x
minus x minus 2y has to be greater than
or equal to minus 3
and x has to be greater than or equal to
0 and
2x minus y has to be greater than or
equal to
0. so those are the complex constraints
so we can write those as real
constraints
so now the region of the complex plane
we can use sort of our implicit region
on these real constraints
and it's going to just be a triangle so
i picked a pretty simple problem here
okay now we can solve linear
optimization on this and suppose we do
real of z okay and
if we do the real it corresponds exactly
to doing this
linear optimization problem on x okay so
we basically
what we do is we internally convert the
complex numbers to these reals
using some some transformations very
much like what i showed you above it's a
bit
bit subtler than that but but not too
different
and then we can compute the compute the
minimum and the real plane then we
convert back to complex numbers at the
end
so it's it's sort of an automatic thing
and
a lot of convex optimization problems
work um typically
um as you get to to higher order things
matrices that in other cases have to be
symmetric need to permission
okay but now here's a slightly subtle
simply less
example this looks very like the same
difficult it's over the same set as
before but now i'm using
abs of z2 minus z minus 2i
so we can do that and it computes the
thing
immediately now it's a little bit hard
to see from this but
absolutely absolute value of z is
is a it's a function it's actually the
modulus which is a square root of
you know you know the real components
plus the imaginary component squared
so it's not actually a linear constraint
anymore so this actually has to be
solved using convex methods that handle
norm what are called norm cone
constraints
and we can go a bit
further and i'm going to take this very
simple problem and i'm going to make it
into a parametric
convex optimization problem so much like
i did before
okay but now instead of having some
arbitrary particular point i put in
minus 2i put in z minus theta and that's
going to be my parameter so my parameter
is going to be some point in the complex
plane okay
so for example i do p fun of one and i
don't know why these boxes come out they
their normal size
outside the slight that's the slideshow
thing but i can also do
p of 2i okay and that gives me the
minimum i had on before so it can be any
point or i could do
p fun of 1 plus 2i okay and we can
actually do a quick manipulate
that allows me to move around this point
in the complex plane
and as i move the point around in the
complex plane and you'll notice
that if i pick carefully i can get to a
point in the center and that's where
and in those cases this is the actual
point i picked in the complex plane and
the minimum
is within that set so it's not at the
boundary
so that's a quick example of a simple
example of how you can use parametric
convex optimization
all right so
so i'm going to take one more example
i'm keeping the number of examples
limited so we can sort of
explore these commands these new things
within a limited set of examples or in
throwing too many examples of
so what i did is i did some timing of
matrix multiplication on my
scene so what i did is i as i timed
matrix multiplication
and for each value of n for each matrix
size
n i did 10 different timings and i
collected data from that
and that i've got stored in the note
rather than having making you suffer
through
waiting for that to come out i've
collected that in advance
and here's a list plot of those timings
so so
so what i'd like to do is i'd like to
sort of find well what is
what is the approximate complexity of
the matrix multiplication
within the wolfram language okay
well this plot makes it pretty hard to
see because you see you have huge
variation here
so typically with things that you're
looking for async particularly if you're
looking for asymptotic timing
it's better to do it in the log log log
plane
and a quick way to do this that i often
use is this function real exponent which
actually just takes a log base 10
but it sort of doesn't worry it doesn't
complain about zeros
or negative numbers it just takes the
absolute value so it's it's actually
more convenient than using
log because it avoids singularities now
notice in this
log plane i can put a plot and actually
it looks pretty close to linear
and in fact the other thing that's
that's useful here is that the variation
in the different components is typically
comparable this first one is quite a bit
bigger but the other ones
it's somewhat comparable so what i want
to do is i'm going to consider this
variation
as sort of a parametric thing and as an
uncertainty
and then do fits based on that view of
the data
okay so first let's think of doing a
linear fit well the way i would normally
do a linear fit
is oh i'm missing something at the
bottom of that slide
um well maybe not um
okay so so yes i'll get the vector i'll
get some data about the log
timing so i'll call tau bar the means of
those timings i have so the mean for
each value of n
and s is the the log of the
n's i had okay which go from 2 to the 8
through 2 to the 12th
and this is going to be the variation
i'll call it delta tau
so the del the variation in the log
space and i've multiplied by this by
three times the actual variation because
i only did 10 realizations
and realistically i'm probably likely to
get more variation
though you know the factor i choose is a
bit arbitrary
okay and here's what the plot looks like
so the variation is shown by the
the vertical bars okay the the expanded
variation
the gray dots the gray large dots show
where the mean is
and then the other dots are just the
plot i showed before the actual data
points
so now let's fit the data well the easy
way to fit the data is just use a
command
fit right we don't need to actually do
optimization it's a linear algebra thing
and i get a fit like this and sort of
the translation to an
actual model asymptotic model is we take
10 to the power of that
and so it's basically some small
coefficient
times n to the 2.84 now of course we
expect that to be
three but realistically there's more
going on than just
the order n cubed of the number of flops
going on there's parallelism
um there's how the machine's cache
behavior works
so it's much more subtle than the actual
mathematical flop
complex complexity which is what makes
it interesting to actually look at this
so now let's look at fitting as
optimization so let's take an objective
function which is
this is going to be the slope of my fit
this is going to be the intercept these
are the points
in in log n space okay
this is my tau bar but i also want to
these are the means
and then i also want to consider an
uncertainty delta which is going to be
bound by those uncertainty models i
found before
so this is my objective and i can do a
simple
so the simple fit i found before is
basically taking the case where delta
equals zero and i can do that with
convex optimization
if i just put in a parametric equation
this is what i call a constant parameter
equation it goes ahead and substitutes
that in and computes and that's exactly
the fit i got with fit
and it's using roughly you know roughly
similar methods
though the fit is a bit more direct so
now let's consider a robust fit
okay so let's do this robust fit oh and
one other thing i forgot to mention in
this
is instead of calling instead of doing
convex optimization
the objective i did convex optimization
of r
where objective is less than root r and
this is this is something you can always
do with convex problems is you can
replace
um some function with some convex
function with
a new variable which in this case is r
and the
additional constraint that objective is
less than or equal to r
and so that's always going to give you
equivalent the equivalent minimum
so convex optimization can actually
always be reduced to the case where we
have a linear objective
now the reason i use the r here is this
actually gives me the residual
instantly so i don't have to go back and
compute it later
i have it as a part of my optimization
so it's just very convenient
now notice here when i do the robust
optimization so i'm
so this is this is a an optimal value
that's that's
valid for all possible values of delta
between these
uncertainty intervals that i had and
notice that
the optimum seems a lot worse the
residual is worse than the one i did in
the simple fit
but it's it looks worse but it's not
really
so let's look at what's happening here
and a different way to look at it so
i've got some functions that are a bit
complicated
okay that sort of compute the worst
error so given a fit
and that possible uncertainty i've
defined a function called worst-paced
plot so let's look at the worst
case plot for the robust fit okay so
basically what i do
is the fit value is here um
and it computes the farthest the
farthest i can go in the uncertainty
that makes that that term and the
residual as
big as possible okay and those are
indicated by the red
and so when i do that for the robust fit
i get that residual which is 0.509 which
is exactly what the robust
residual had given me so basically for
any value in the uncertainty
okay the most the residual is ever going
to be is that value
that that value given so so if it varies
uncertainly i
have this this property now let's look
at the simple fit
okay the worst case for the simple fit
we actually get a worse residual
so in cases where the data don't work
out
properly you can get a worse residual
than the robust fit and that's the
reason to use the robust fit and
peritosh will show some examples that
indicate you know if you want to have to
order if you're a manufacturer you need
to order based on some
estimate it's better to make a
conservative estimate than risk not
making any profit at all
okay so let's continue with this problem
a bit further
okay and let's look at a parametric view
of it so here i'm going to change the
objective
to get rid of the deci the uncertainty
and i'll just consider the the tau or
the
the timings i got for a particular
instance
okay and i'm going to call it a
parametric fit function so not
surprisingly if i call this parametric
fix function with my mean
timings i get exactly that same fit i
got before that simple fit
okay so i can do a whole bunch of fits
okay
of all the the 10 inches of the timing i
did and i get something like this
it's more used to actually compare state
of the robust fit you see i'm getting
within you know 0.05 or so
i'm getting slopes and intercepts which
vary quite a bit
okay so let's go a bit further with the
robust optimization so let's consider
the standard deviation so let's assume
that
the timings we get out of the machine
which i think is not an unreasonable
assumption are normally distribution
distributed around the means so let's
get a standard deviation
let's get a thousand instances of that
okay
and i'll get a thousand instances using
random variate
okay and then what i'm going to do with
that is i'm going to
go ahead and fit those
okay each of those thousand instances
and actually
i think my computers before this total
only took like a second but i think it's
because it's doing the talk and
everything at once
okay so now let's go ahead and
look at the envelope of the possible
models
okay so these are all the possible
models from the
this is very similar to before we've
again based it compared to the robust
optimization so you can kind of see the
envelope
something else you know which is quite
interesting is you can use the find
distribution function to find what is
the distribution of these fits
okay and it turns out that the slope is
normally distributed
or you know approximately normally
distributed with the mean
and you can actually look at the pdf
with the histogram
in this plot and so that's the the
slopes
and the intercepts so it's really very
much centered around 2.85 so we can be
pretty confident this that this slope
is not actually 3 but it's something
less than that and again that
that makes sense because of the the
parallelism
okay so now let's look at another idea
um which is the sensitivity okay so
so suppose you want to know how the
derivative
of the fit and this again you take the
derivative
and because it's a vector parameter we
use this
a vector inside the first argument of
derivative so it's not just a prime it's
particularly one particular component of
the thing
okay and we can find the derivative so
basically this says that
you know if i were to change the first
component
okay the derivative the slope changes by
you know that times delta the first
component
and the residual actually decreases as
the first component
increases which makes sense okay
now something else you want to be able
to do and this is this is this is a view
into the future
is we're going to eventually have a
design that allow you to get all of
these
the gradient with respect to all of
these parameters at once so
here i'm taking this is in the function
space so this would be the third
component of the function which is the
residual
and so if i do this this gives me the
gradient
of the residual respect to all the
parameters at once and so notice this
matches this and
for interest of time i don't have more
to go into this but this will actually
tie into automatic differentiation that
we'll eventually have in the compiler as
well
um okay so now it's time to talk about
future plans
okay so um
um this this is a mistake i should have
gotten rid of that but
okay so things we're going to work on in
the future is stochastic optimization
and actually that example i showed you
where i got the distribution
is an example of stochastic optimization
well actually mathematically be able to
get the distributions properly
and there's a few different techniques
in that another is multi-objective
authorization so what if you have
trade-offs between you know so do two
different things you want to sort of
weigh those we get
you know optimal values along with the
so-called pareto front
and then the next thing we're going to
start working on is global nonlinear
optimization there's all sorts of
techniques now
general global nonlinear optimization we
haven't find minimum
and minimize it sort of works but it
often runs into problem as
that many of you found so what we're
going to try and do is is use
some particular techniques that are that
show great promise and we can actually
get really good solutions for and we're
going to try and classify problems as
much as possible
using the symbolic part of the wolf
dimension okay so one is quasi-convex
optimization this is just an extension
of
convex optimization and linear
fractional programming as an example
and it will extend the log convex
optimization to be more general
we'll have what's called difference of
convex optimization so that's a convex
function
minus plus a concave function which is
or a convex function minus some other
convex
function and all um twice differentiable
functions
are in this class we're going to set up
a framework for branch and bound a
general framework that would allow us to
do things like
using convex approximations um
and using envelope calculations on that
and then we'll have stochastic methods
kind of that's kind of like the random
search
and minimize but it'll have much
improved efficiencies
because it'll use some of these faster
methods online we'll also eventually do
some sophisticated problem classes one
we're sort of starting to look at now is
say
you know packing problems how do you
pack pallets into an airplane or how do
you
do floor design to pack things in
so those are things coming in the the
near future i mean the long-term future
will eventually have
sort of n minimize and fine minimum
really souped up
um to work very efficiently in
you know a huge number of cases so to
kind of conclude i'm going to
do this so i'm going to show you one
more example with convex optimization
and so i'm going to take an image which
is corrupted that i showed in my
original title slot it actually looks
like this
and the idea is what you do is i've got
a bunch of pixels that have been
kind of zeroed out and i want to sort of
restore the image as much as possible
well
a way to do that is to minimize this
total variation which is a
a sum of norms of each component each
pixel
with its nearby pixels so you minimize
that
okay and then
so a trick for actually doing this
efficiently is to use the sparse array
of the data and you can
this is a quick way to find zeros and i
want to keep
all the the pixels that weren't zeroed
at the original values
okay then i do um
i set up constraints which are the
variations
and i'm doing this with
conic optimization one of our our
solvers
and this takes a bit of time um and i'll
go ahead and enter this
and eventually it will show up but in
the meantime
you can ask any questions that you you
may have
you can start asking questions now
now let me see if i can find my chat
i'm going to minimize this
and there was one question in the chat
oh this is not
maybe because my computer is um is um
bogged down computing that's because
this is a fairly large far
large minimization problem um
but one question that was asked in the
the chat for the uh
for the pathable um thing was
you know could we could we add a
performance goal to n minimize
and actually i think that's a really
good idea ah so it finally did this
and if you see we got a corrected
corrected image
um so so the the answer to the question
is you know can we
and add a performance goal to find
minimum and minimize and the answer is
yes we'll do that we may not do this for
this next version but we should have
something fairly soon and in fact all of
these convex optimization functions
we've
we've put together do have a performance
goal and they kind of do a trade-off
between
tolerance and the automatic tolerance
and i think that's a really good idea
for n minimize so we'll
we'll have that before too long
so let's see so there's a whole bunch of
questions
um i'll look at that okay so
um yes i'll figure out somebody will
tell me how to add the notebook and i'll
add it somehow
that's that's past my level of
technology um
but michael your question was the
residual given um
earlier defined or just a free variable
so so the residual as i showed in that
as as an objective r was a was a free
variable that i added but it's it's
going to when it when it finds the
optimum it's going to be equal to that
minimum value of the objective i don't
know if that completely answers your
question and then is there a general
class of functions that can be
transformed into convex problems
well the answer is yes but it's not
going to be very satisfying
convex functions can be transformed
transformed into convex problems
um and and
what for for the john general nonlinear
case that we're considering is
functions that can be approximated
closely by convex functions
that's where we'll look into the branch
and bound methods that we we get a
convex envelope
approximation and then we see how good
that is by using a
branch and brown framework to define
that
okay i think we're good i think we're
actually out of time now so
so thank you for your attention